JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Hello, you've joined
us live at Google I/O.
I'm Jake and this is Paul.
And Paul, I don't
know about you,
but when I have
a handheld mike I
find it changes my
personality and accents.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What
things in the keynote
particularly caught
your attention?
PAUL LEWIS: Can
we drop this now?
Actually, I think I
was going to say this,
I think for me it was
Chrome Custom Tabs.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Chrome custom tabs.
They were brilliant, yes.
PAUL LEWIS: You can
have that back now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
Chrome custom tabs.
They were really-- I mean we've
seen native apps do this also
so far with like web views.
They're keeping
you within the app
by using a web view of them
calling out into a browser.
But this has a few
problems, right?
PAUL LEWIS: So I was noticing
this with the Twitter app
where it takes you to
the Twitter web view.
And then it basically makes
you sign into Twitter again.
So you're like signing into
Twitter, inside of Twitter,
inside of Twitter and it was
like Twitter's all the way
down.
And I was like this is
bizarre, don't want to do this.
And Chrome custom tabs
let's you break out
that-- gives you Chrome
with all the Cookie
Jar, all that good stuff.
But it gives you the
niceties of still feeling
like you're part of the
app that you were in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think there's
a security element to this
as well.
Because I don't know
about you but whenever
I'm using a native app and
it starts showing web content
but within its own
view, if I get a login
screen for something
like Twitter or Google
I don't have the confidence
that I'm actually
looking at a Twitter
or a Google property.
It could just be any website
that just kind of has
a page that looks like that.
And with the Chrome custom
tabs, it gives you confidence
that you're on the real
web, you can find the URL,
you have that
safety and security.
PAUL LEWIS: Yep, so
I think, what else?
Oh, we saw ServiceWorker is
still getting a lot-- woo!--
lot of love and attention.
And obviously that
gives rise to push
messaging and notifications
as well as sort of as a
follow on from that.
And obviously, in
the next year I
guess we might see even
more things hanging off
Service worker like
background sync,
maybe if that comes through.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yeah, Yeah, we've
got-- background sync is
in progress at the moment.
I guess the main
difference for this year
is, because I was
presenting last year,
and I was on stage
kind of saying,
hey we've kind of
made a prototype.
Look it kind of works.
Well the demos kind of worked.
Though we had some issues.
And we were like maybe this
is going to be a thing,
hopefully we don't
break the web forever.
And so it's kind of been almost
reassuring to see this year
people like the Guardian
are actually using it
for push notifications.
And we've seen people use
it to make the web faster
and that's kind of like,
yeah, we didn't actually
destroy everything.
Go, us.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
I think we've also
been hearing a lot about
performance, which obviously
makes me very happy.
And it's nice to see that
that's getting a lot of airtime
again at I/O this year.
So we've been talking about
Rail and stuff like that.
And then Polymer hit 1.0.
Which means now they're
production ready.
What was that?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
was me trying to do 1.0.
PAUL LEWIS: That
just does not look--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Like I
did it right way around?
Yeah that's right.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
but it's just weird.
Don't do it.
It's weird.
Unless I can get
you in to actually
sign for every single version
of an app bigger than 1.1.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
easier now because when
they naught point--
PAUL LEWIS: Five-- Eight--
Eight's fine but try and do
five.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
the wrong way around.
Yeah, OK.
PAUL LEWIS: All right,
but in any case,
that's really awesome.
That means components
hopefully starting
to standardize and settle down.
And can start to make its
way and move things forward.
Well what else have
you been noticing?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The Photos
app and their website
which is coming soon.
Which I'm really, really
looking forward to seeing what
they've done.
I think for me
it's just-- the web
has taken another huge
chunk out of native,
in terms of features
and performance, while.
But it's remained-- it's
kept true to the web.
And I think one
the things that we
saw in the keynote was
like Android saying, hey,
we're going to do this
permission model where
you ask for permissions
just before you use them
because then they've
got context and stuff.
And I sat there going, yes,
that's what the web does.
We win, for once.
So I think we're going to see
more of that sort of stuff
and improving the
web but keeping
what makes the web great.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]